This is the brief on that big
debate.
Is America basically a graveyard
for social movements?
OK, so here's the idea, right?
It's pretty provocative.
It compares America to
Afghanistan.
You know, the famous graveyard
of empires.
Does America just kind of absorb
big moral crusades, drain all
their energy, and let them fade
away?
Let's breakdown the three main
ways people see this.
First, you've got the graveyard
argument itself.
It goes like this.
America seems to play along with
movements, right?
Think civil rights or maybe
diversity.
Equity and inclusion programs
DEI.
It throws some money, sets up
some committees.
But deep down, there's this
powerful inertia, this
resistance to real change, and
eventually the movement just
runs out of steam.
That's the entropy part.
And things quietly slide back.
Schools might resegregate, DEI
gets dismantled.
You get the picture.
OK, but then there's the
pushback.
The second view says, hold on.
America isn't a graveyard.
It's more like an evolving
battleground.
Here, movements don't just die.
They kind of compost, they leave
something behind.
Progress isn't always a straight
line.
It layers up, it morphs, and get
this, the backlash, that's
actually proof the movement had
an impact.
Think about Occupy Wall Street.
It might be gone, but we all
talk about the 1% now, right?
That language stuck.
So which is it?
A graveyard or a compost heap?
Well, that brings us to the
third idea, kind of a synthesis.
Maybe it's less about dying and
more about being preserved.
This view suggests America is
like a mausoleum with Wi-Fi
movements like Hashtag Me Too or
Black Lives Matter.
Get hashtag shared.
Even monetized online, they look
alive, always curated, always
visible.
But does that curated version
actually lead to deep structural
change or just keep the illusion
going while the real energy
fades?
It really makes you think about
speed versus staying power.
So yeah, the struggle for
justice here, it feels like this
constant tug of war between that
deep cultural inertia and the
slow, layered build up of change
over time.
Welcome to the deep dive.
We are diving into a comparison
today that, well, at first
glance it sounds like pure
dramatic hyperbole.
Maybe.
It definitely grabs your
attention.
It does, but I promise you when
you actually look at the source
material we have, it becomes
this intellectually really
rigorous and high stakes
conflict.
The core question before us is
this is America fundamentally A
graveyard, not for, you know,
foreign armies or empires, but
for the social movements, the
ones that attempt to
fundamentally change its culture
and politics.
That is certainly a provocative
analogy.
To kick things off, our
listeners sent us 2 incredibly
ripped sources that are, well,
they're locked in direct
intellectual combat.
Really.
Right.
We have one powerful, if maybe
deeply skeptical, essay arguing
for that graveyard hypothesis.
OK, the idea that American
culture has this like, systemic,
highly effective way of
absorbing, exhausting and then
ultimately neutralizing the
energy of reformers.
OK, absorbing, exhausting,
neutralizing.
Got it.
And then the counter.
And then we have the equally
detailed and I think really
thoughtful rebuttal.
This counter source insists
that, you know, viewing these
apparent failures as a
graveyard.
That's just cynicism mistaken
for realism.
OK, so it's not realism, it's
pessimism.
Pretty much.
It argues that change isn't
vanishing, it's sedimenting.
It layers itself, you know, into
the foundation of society, often
in ways that maybe we don't
immediately recognize.
Sedimenting like layers building
up over time.
Interesting.
Exactly.
So our mission today is to
unpack this.
Well, it's high stakes
intellectual sparring match for
you, the listener.
It's really an argument about
the fundamental nature of
American progress.
Does the change stick?
Does the change brought by these
massive movements actually last,
or is it just temporary?
Right.
The first source suggests A
frankly depressing conclusion
that maybe all progress is
ultimately reversible because
the culture just fundamentally
resists disruption.
But the second source says the
complete opposite, that progress
is recursive.
It builds on past struggles,
even when those struggles might
have looked like failures at the
time.
Recursive like it loops back and
builds on itself.
So we're going to be looking at
the core forces then that shape
cultural resistance and change.
Yeah, and it's a battle defined
by these really interesting
metaphors, Inertia, entropy,
compost and landfills.
Inertia, entropy, compost,
landfills.
That sets up the conflict.
Clearly it defines whether you
should look at American idealism
as, I guess, a tragedy, or maybe
as a complex slow motion victory
that just needs constant
vigilance.
That's the core tension.
OK, let's get started.
Let's dig into Section 1, the
graveyard hypothesis.
OK, let's unpack this core,
really startling analogy from
the first source.
The author kicks off by defining
Afghanistan as the graveyard of
empires, a name it earned, you
know, through centuries of
frustrating foreign
intervention, the British, the
Soviets, and, most recently, the
United States.
Yeah, and that phrase graveyard
of empires, it's used not just
like dramatically, but almost
scientifically in the source.
The source defines it as this
kind of geopolitical truth
rooted in a really profound
cultural endurance.
Afghanistan's winning strategy,
it argues, has never really been
about defeating superior
military forces in, you know,
open battle.
It is about outlasting them.
It plays the long game.
Just waiting them out.
Exactly.
It simply waits for the foreign
armies and governments to use up
all their energy, all their
political will, their resources,
knowing they have, well,
eternity on their side,
essentially.
And this waiting game involves a
kind of surface compliance,
right?
The source argues that's key to
its success.
Yes, highly deceptive, almost
like an act of strategic passive
resistance.
Afghanistan will, you know,
accept the money, the aid, the
resources.
Take the help, Take the help.
It allows superficial changes,
maybe A few schools get built in
the cities, new laws are briefly
enforced, foreign ideals get
promoted in the media.
They control that kind of thing.
But underneath.
But underneath that veneer, that
surface compliance, the loyalty
to the older ways, to the
tribes, the local identity, the
enduring religious structures,
that remains strong, it's
hidden.
It's untouched.
So the local people, yeah, they
smile, nod, take the cash.
Yeah, they say what the
occupiers want to hear, maybe,
but they keep their core
identity intact.
They're just waiting for the
occupying force to blink 1st to
get tired.
So if the foreign force drained
and you know, eventually
defeated by exhaustion, leaves,
what happens then according to
this analogy?
Afghanistan simply shrugs it all
off.
Everything they tried to build,
that's the core mechanism
described.
Wow.
The foreign funded schools
close, the new laws vanished,
the Western systems collapse and
the culture returns, sometimes
almost violently, to its
previous state.
All that effort just buried
wasted energy.
Wasted energy buried in silence.
That's the picture painted.
And here's the really
provocative twist.
The source supplies this exact
like 4 stage mechanism directly
to America.
But the invaders here aren't
armies, they're social
movements.
Exactly.
In the American cultural
context, the invaders are the
Crusades, the slogans, the
demands for systemic change,
whether it's, you know,
environmentalism, racial
justice, gender equality, you
name it.
They arrive with protests, maybe
massive corporate campaigns, and
this undeniable moral mission to
shift the culture.
And crucially, initially, it
looks like they're succeeding.
Like wildly succeeding.
So the system's response isn't
like violent suppression,
because that might spark a real
revolution.
Right, According to this source,
that's not the tactic.
Instead, the American system
plays along.
It opens the door wide and
immediately starts dumping
resources into the movement.
Dumping resources like what?
Companies declare allegiance,
you know, throwing corporate
funding at it.
Suddenly it becomes an instant,
often highly profitable cause.
Governments rewrite rules.
Schools create new DEI programs.
Activists might transition into
highly paid institutional jobs.
I see.
So they get brought inside the
system.
Precisely.
And this is where the core
critique of Source One really
lies.
This initial compliance gives
reformers a completely false,
maybe even intoxicating, belief
that they are winning and
winning easily.
Because the system isn't
fighting them, it's integrating.
Them, it's integrating them,
yeah.
Which brings us to the draining
mechanism.
This feels counterintuitive.
The essay argues that throwing
massive amounts of money
attention institutional approval
that actually drains the
movement's authentic, maybe
revolutionary energy faster.
Why?
It's a really interesting point
because the movement spends its
finite energy pushing against
what seems like a yielding
surface, pushing for easy
surface level wins.
Right, with a new corporate
mandate or a celebrity
endorsement.
We're trending hashtag exactly.
The energy just disperses into
this like bureaucratic
institutional ether.
Activists might go from
organizing radical change on the
streets to managing internal
corporate communications.
So the passion gets converted
into job security and memos.
Pretty much.
That's the argument.
It's the ultimate cooptation.
It's not a violent defeat.
It's what the source actually
calls death by 1000 supportive
memos.
Wow, death by 1000 supportive
That's grim.
It is the movement exhausts
itself, pushing into this
institutional landscape that
seems receptive, only to find
that the core cultural inertia,
that loyalty to the old ways, it
remains solid.
He just waited it.
Out, and the source says there's
a consistent historical pattern
here.
Yes, cited again and again.
Big surge, then surface
compliance, followed inevitably
by the rollback and fade.
OK, let's run through the
specific historical examples
used to sort of prove this
pattern.
The Civil Rights movement as the
first one, maybe the most
painful example cited in this
light.
Yeah, I mean it.
One huge federal laws, right?
Outlawing segregation.
Securing voting rights.
Massive victories.
Absolutely huge.
But the author notes that while
the laws changed on paper, the
cultural reality often snapped
back decades later.
You see, funding for integrated
schools evaporate, local zoning
laws creating de facto
resegregation and housing.
Right, the enforcement dwindles.
Enforcement of federal mandates
dwindled as the political
pressure faded.
The energy just ran out and the
systemic inertial forces,
racism, economic division, they
quietly return things to
something approximating the
status quo, albeit maybe under
different legal terms.
OK, so the form changes but the
substance remains.
That's the argument.
Then you have affirmative
action.
It fundamentally shifted who was
in higher education.
Professional fields for decades
provided critical opportunities.
Definitely a huge impact.
But what happened?
It faced decades of attrition,
legal challenges, cultural
resentment until it was
gradually weakened, dismantled
at the state level and then
ultimately rolled back by the
Supreme Court.
So the initial force dissipated.
The initial force dissipated and
the system leveraged its legal
institutions to kind of restore
the previous equilibrium.
What about something faster like
Occupy Wall Street?
That's a key example for rapid
dissipation.
It filled city centers with
protests, right?
Dramatically transformed the
public conversation around
wealth disparity.
The 1% Huge visibility.
Yeah, everyone was talking
about.
It And yet its physical presence
vanished almost overnight.
Its immediate legislative impact
was minimal, and the physical
organizing capacity just
evaporated once the police swept
the encampments.
Gone quickly and the recent
examples you mentioned happened
even faster, proving the
mechanism is maybe accelerating.
Well, the source suggests it's
still very active DEI programs.
For instance, they became
mandatory almost everywhere
following major cultural shifts,
right?
Felt like overnight.
But the source highlights
they're now being quietly
dismantled or facing massive
political and corporate backlash
that's leading to hiring
freezes, restructuring.
Swift reversal.
Or look at the trans rights
campaigns made massive cultural
waves very quickly achieve
recognition policy shifts in
some areas.
Yes, significant gains.
Yet in response, laws and
policies are now being rapidly
reversed across multiple states,
particularly targeting youth
participation, healthcare.
So the compliance window was
really brief before the
resistance kicked in hard.
Extremely brief, yeah, the
inertial resistance, as the
source puts it.
And the reason for this pattern,
according to this source, isn't
really about ideology, it's
attributed to physics.
Kind of, yeah.
Two powerful scientific forces
that shape culture, inertia and
entropy.
OK, explain inertia in this
cultural context.
So inertia here is the massive
tendency of a society, a
culture, to stay exactly the
same.
Imagine like a gigantic cultural
body at rest.
OK, it stays at rest unless a
continuous, enormous and really
exhausting effort is applied to
push it.
The moment that push stops it's
aspect, culture, like physics,
wants to return to its
comfortable starting state.
The status quo is always the
path of least resistance.
It takes constant energy to keep
things changed.
Got it.
And then there's entropy.
Right.
Entropy is that slow, inevitable
decay of order into disorder.
Think about new systems, new
laws, new habits, and they
require constant maintenance,
energy input like upkeep.
Exactly.
If the initial moral fervor
fades, if activists move on to
other things, entropy simply
begins to erase the gains.
Bureaucracy decays.
The new standards are forgotten.
Accountability disappears.
It just falls apart if you stop
actively holding it together.
It's like stopping the
maintenance on a highly complex
computer system, right?
It won't crash instantly, but it
will slowly, inexorably fail
until the original disorder or
maybe the previous state
returns.
So the conclusion of this first
deeply skeptical perspective is
pretty stark, then.
It is America functions as a
cultural black hole.
It swallows the energy, the
enthusiasm, the reforms, the
hard won surface victories of
the movement.
Call of everything.
Absorbs everything, converts
that energy into institutional
exhaustion, maybe apathy, and
then returns to its original
state, weary of the effort
required to fend off the change
in the first place.
Wow, OK, that is a profoundly
bleak assessment.
A cultural black hole.
If that's true.
I mean, why do people keep
fighting?
Why is this intellectual tension
so persistent?
That's the perfect question, and
it's precisely where the second
source steps in with a really
vigorous rebuttal.
It calls that graveyard analogy
cynicism mistaken for realism.
OK, cynicism mistaken for
realism.
I like that framing.
So what's the core argument
here?
The core argument is that change
doesn't vanish it's sediments.
Sedimentation again.
OK, explain that.
The counter perspective
immediately challenges this idea
of a simple snapback.
It argues that movements don't
actually disappear.
They morph, they fracture, maybe
they adapt, and they often
return.
So they don't die, they
transform.
Exactly.
The claim that America just
returns to its original state
ignores the durable, often
invisible changes that remain
layered into the foundation of
society.
What the essay calls recursive
progress.
Recursive progress, meaning it
builds on itself.
OK, let's test that.
Where is the evidence of this
sedimentation in those very
examples that source one claimed
were definitive failures?
Where are the building blocks
left behind?
OK, great question.
Let's take the civil rights
movement again.
Source One focuses on the quiet
resegregation, right?
Right, the rollback.
This source argues that yes,
that happened, but the movement
also fundamentally reshaped not
just the federal legal
landscape, but public
consciousness in a way that is
irreversible.
OK.
Consciousness shift.
And crucially, it established
the legal and rhetorical
foundation for subsequent
struggles.
The infrastructure of justice.
You know, the legal templates,
the language of rights, the
mechanisms for challenging state
power that was largely built by
the civil rights movement.
So it laid the groundwork.
It laid the groundwork that
became the soil for disability
rights, for LGBTQ plus rights,
for immigrant rights movements.
Decades later, they use the
tools created earlier.
So the argument is that even if
the immediate goal was partially
rolled back, the possibility and
the structure for future justice
was permanently secure.
That's the idea.
Or look at the courts rolling
back affirmative action source
to insist that effort was far
from useless.
Oh so.
It's cultural legacy.
Think about the decades of
diverse hiring practices, the
whole generation of highly
visible professionals of color
who became teachers, doctors,
lawyers because of it.
That cannot simply be erased by
a court ruling.
Right.
Those people exist.
Their influence exists.
It's a permanent demographic and
maybe more importantly, an
expectation shift that persists
outside of any any specific
court mandate.
The culture changed.
OK, that makes sense.
What about Occupy Wall Street?
Source One said it vanished
overnight.
Yeah, Source 2 has a very
different take.
The counter argument is that it
profoundly transformed the
political lexicon.
The language we use.
Exactly.
Terms like the 1% and income
inequality.
They went from being like niche
academic concepts to mainstream
issues almost overnight.
That's true.
You hear them constantly, Yeah.
And that shapes legislation, it
shapes electoral platforms
across the political spectrum
today.
Every politician now has to have
some answer on inequality,
right?
That change is directly
traceable to Occupies rhetoric.
So the movement wasn't
physically erased.
Its vocabulary, its core
concerns got absorbed, but not
as poison like source one
suggested.
Not as poison, but as new,
indelible building blocks into
the civic language.
That's the argument.
The focus shifts from the
dramatic visibility of the
protest itself to the
persistence of the ideas and the
structures built by that initial
energy.
OK, that's a powerful counter.
Let's revisit inertia.
Source One framed it as the
absolute enemy of progress, the
force always pulling things
back.
Right, the big bad force.
Source 2 offers a significantly
different, more complex view.
It describes inertia as,
paradoxically, democracy's
safety mechanism.
How does that work?
This is a really crucial pivot
in the argument.
The slowness, the frustration,
the institutional inertia that
activists rightly complain
about, that is in many ways the
necessary price of maintaining A
deliberative democracy.
The price of stability.
Kind of Inertia acts as a shock
absorber.
It prevents rapid radical
overcorrections that could
quickly lead to tyranny or even
civil war.
Liberal democracy is
fundamentally reliant on
deliberation on incrementalism.
Which is frustrating.
Super frustrating to activists,
but it's also what keeps
movements, however powerful they
seem in the moment, from
instantly becoming purges or
causing complete societal
breakdown.
So if change happens slowly,
that's not necessarily a sign of
failure.
It's proof this system is
working as designed to maximize
stability, prevent chaos.
That's the interpretation.
The culture resists traumatic
shifts because stability itself
is seen as a foundational good,
maybe the foundational good.
OK.
And this leads directly to the
central, really powerful
metaphor of the rebuttal.
Movements aren't buried in a
graveyard.
They compost.
OK, I love that idea.
Explain the composting metaphor
in a cultural sense.
Yeah, the compost metaphor is
really at the core of Source
twos, optimism movements, even
while they might decay, lose
their immediate institutional
power, maybe fade from the
headlines, they break down into
the soil of public life.
OK.
And that decay fertilizes future
growth.
It provides these essential
nourishment, the political
precedents, the moral urgency,
the network connections
necessary for the next wave of
activism to emerge and hopefully
emerge stronger.
So the material isn't wasted or
buried.
It's repurposed.
It becomes fertilizer.
Exactly.
It's repurposed.
To give us some examples of this
composting process in action.
Where can we see that?
OK, think about the feminist
movement of the 1970s.
That wave secured things like
tidal and eyes.
Normalize the language of
women's leadership to some
extent.
Did it vanish?
Source 2 says no.
That work broke down, composted,
and decades later it directly
fueled the hashtag me too era.
The earlier movements legal
frameworks, its cultural
critiques, its institutional
networks, Those were used built
upon by the later movement.
Which arguably reached an even
higher altitude of impact
because the soil was richer.
OK, building on the past, what
else?
Similarly, think about the 1960s
anti war protests.
They led to this deep cultural
skepticism toward foreign
interventionism that is now
almost bipartisan.
Wouldn't you say?
Yeah, that feels true.
Much more caution now.
Right.
Even if a specific anti war
movement failed to stop Vietnam
or failed to stop the Iraq war,
the resulting compost ensured
that every future administration
has to justify foreign wars far
more rigorously than ever
before.
The ground shifted.
The default change.
The default changed, and perhaps
most significantly in recent
memory, Black Lives Matter.
Even if the massive St. protests
quieted down, the source argues,
it permanently shifted public
opinion on policing, on
incarceration, on systemic
racism across key demographics.
You see it in polling data in
conversation.
It changed the conversation
permanently.
It built in during local
institutions.
It changed media reporting
standards.
It provided the language and
framework that continues to re
emerge under new names and
faces.
The energy might have dispersed,
but the structure, the compost,
remains ready for the next
cycle.
OK, let's move to the idea of
backlash.
Source One saw the rollback, the
push against DEI, the attacks on
affirmative action as proof the
system was winning.
Right?
Proof of the graveyard.
Yeah, proof of the inevitable
snapback.
Source 2 completely flicks this.
It argues the backlash is simply
proof of impact.
Absolutely.
The source insists that when
entrenched powerful hierarchies,
whether that's white supremacy,
patriarchy, corporate oligarchy,
whatever, when they feel
threatened, they fight back.
So the fight back means you
landed a blow.
Exactly.
If the movement was irrelevant,
if it hadn't actually changed
anything, there would just be
silence.
The fact that political groups
are spending massive resources
today to rollback DEI policies
or limit reproductive freedom,
that's definitive evidence that
the preceding movement worked.
It forced a political contest.
So it's not a racer, it's just
the next phase of the struggle.
It's the next necessary front in
an ongoing democratic struggle.
It's proof of life, not death.
And finally, the rebuttal
insists that America is
fundamentally different from
that Afghanistan analogy because
the movement leaders aren't
foreign invaders, the source
says.
We are the system.
Yeah, this is a crucial
philosophical distinction, I
think.
Afghanistan successfully
resisted empires because the
invaders were always external,
right?
Imposing alien values.
Outsiders in America, the
reformers, the civil rights
marchers, the climate activists,
the organizers for social
justice, they are citizens.
They are part of the fabric of
the nation itself.
So the fight is internal.
The fight for justice is America
happening to us, to itself.
The essay suggests the system
cannot truly wait out its own
people in the same way, because
the people are the system.
The struggle is internal,
dynamic and therefore
fundamentally necessary and
maybe unavoidable.
OK, so we've established these
two powerful competing
worldviews, the graveyard of
exhaustion versus the evolving
battleground of compost.
This last section is where the
sources seem to push past just
simple disagreement right and
engage in a higher level
analysis of what success even
looks like.
Yeah, this is where it gets
really nuanced.
Both sides, interestingly, seem
to agree on one basic point.
Things change, and change does
accumulate over time.
OK, so they agree change
happens.
They agree change happens, but
the divergent really sharpens on
the questions of velocity and
retention.
How fast does it happen and how
much actually sticks?
Right.
The graveyard view focuses on
that rapid enthusiasm, the quick
burnout, the systemic absorption
that neutralizes the energy.
Quick burn, quick fade.
While the compost view focuses
on the slow, maybe agonizing
layering that eventually adds up
to something durable, even if it
takes generations.
Slow build deep roots.
Exactly.
Let's return to inertia one last
time.
Source 2 championed it earlier
as a safety mechanism protecting
stability.
Right the shock absorber for
democracy.
But the critique offered later,
even within that second source,
challenges this positive view.
It argues inertia isn't actually
a neutral force, it's biased.
Yes, that's a fantastic
distinction raised later on.
The source notes that cultural
inertia does not treat all
shocks equally.
It cushions wealth and
entrenched power much, much
better than it Christians
demands for justice.
How so?
Give an example.
Well, inertia doesn't just
protect stability in the
abstract, it protects the
beneficiaries of that existing
stability.
So the institutional slowness of
democracy might protect against,
say, dictators, sure, which is
good, which is good.
But it also, in the words of the
source, keeps landlords rich and
entrenched, corporations
dominant.
It makes challenging that kind
of power incredibly difficult
and slow.
So it reframes inertia not as
just a neutral shock absorber,
but as a deliberate heavy
protector of the existing
distribution of power and
wealth.
Exactly.
It has a thumb on the scale.
OK, this leads directly into a
really critical discussion about
what actually happens to the
movements material, its energy.
If it's not simply buried
graveyard and it's not always
composting, what's the third
option?
The source calls it the landfill
problem.
Right, the landfill problem.
This is the concept of descent
metabolize.
Descent.
Metabolize.
Yeah.
Does the energy truly re enter
the civic soil you know
available for future growth like
compost?
Or is it merely contained,
sealed off, packaged?
Like putting trash in a landfill
liner.
Precisely the critical analysis
here suggests that America's
consumer culture, its corporate
culture, has marketers, not
gardeners.
The movements authentic radical
moral energy gets converted into
brand content.
Into something sellable.
Sellable, easily digestible,
easily ignored.
Once the trend passes, it
becomes cultural waste sealed
away, not fertile soil.
OK, give us the concrete
examples of this corporate
containment, this landfill
effect where the movements power
is neutralized by basically
turning it into a product.
Yeah, think about how feminism
often becomes empowerment
branding.
Yeah, everywhere.
Right.
A struggle for fundamental legal
and economic equality gets
repurposed to sell makeup or
clothing lines, or maybe
aspirational corporate programs
that, you know, change very
little about the actual wage gap
or power structures.
OK, what about racial justice?
Black Lives Matter, the source
argues, often gets reduced to a
diversity memo, an HR directive,
maybe a mandatory seminar.
Performative.
Exactly.
Rather than a fundamental
redistribution of resources or a
real change in police
accountability structures, it's
contained within the existing
corporate or institutional
framework.
And environmentalism, same
pattern.
Same pattern The urgent moral
crisis gets converted into what?
A carbon trading app or a
marketing campaign that sells
you flights under the guise of
offsetting your footprint.
Right, solving the problem by
consuming more.
Exactly.
The system uses the moral fervor
of the movement to circulate
outrage, maybe generate clicks
and AD revenue, and ultimately
profit from it, all while
maintaining the basic
equilibrium and giving the
illusion of progress.
It's what the source calls the
tragic comedy of American
idealism.
That's quite a phrase.
It is.
We are the system, right?
That means every reformer is
fundamentally funded by the very
economy they critique, amplified
by the algorithms that profit
from their outrage, hosted on
the platforms that monetize
their descent.
So we don't overthrow the
system, we just refresh its user
interface.
That's the bleak suggestion.
The fight is happening inside
the machine, which means the
system itself benefits from the
churn, from the constant updates
and arguments.
Which brings us to the ultimate
contrast in historical
viewpoints presented is the
process a spiral or a treadmill?
Yeah, 2 very different images of
history.
The optimistic view, the compost
view maybe holds that history is
a spiral.
We revisit old ground fighting
for voting rights again, or
economic fairness again, but we
do it at a slightly higher
altitude each time.
Having learned lessons, build
better tools.
Having learned lessons, built
more inclusive systems, maybe on
top of the old ones.
Progress but slow and looping.
OK.
And the skeptical view?
The skeptical view The treadmill
view argues that it's perpetual
churn with 0 net displacement.
We are running extremely hard,
experiencing great exhaustion,
constantly updating the scenery.
New laws, new hashtags, new
language.
Right, the scenery updates, but
the systemic arrangement of
power, the incline of the
treadmill, it remains almost
identical.
So it feels like forward motion,
but it's just maintaining the
same systemic arrangement, the
same people benefit.
The status quo remains
comfortable for those at the
top.
That's the treadmill argument,
and this leads to the final and
maybe the most powerful full
counter metaphor offered by this
refined analysis.
In the second source, America
isn't a graveyard because that
implies death and forgetting.
OK, not a graveyard.
It is a mausoleum with Wi-Fi.
A mausoleum with Wi-Fi?
OK, unpack.
That mausoleum suggests careful
curation, preservation, not just
burial or decay.
Exactly.
Think about our movements.
Civil rights, pride.
Hashtag me too.
They are all still highly
visible, aren't they?
Yeah.
Constantly referenced.
They are preserved behind glass
#illuminated, sometimes
monetized.
Curation becomes the tool of
neutralization.
The movement doesn't disappear.
It becomes a piece of history,
an exhibit in the museum.
It is accessible.
That's the Wi-Fi part.
You can look it up, learn about
it.
It's studied.
It's even celebrated on
holidays.
Right, like Black History Month
or Pride Month.
Exactly.
But the very act of preserving
it behind glass, curating it, it
neutralizes its radical living
power, its ability to challenge
the present order.
So nothing disappears, but maybe
nothing breathes.
Nothing truly threatens the
status quo anymore.
That's the chilling suggestion
of the mausoleum metaphor.
It's kept alive as an artifact,
but it's active forces contained
hashtag tag outro.
Wow.
We've covered some truly
remarkable intellectual ground
today, really digging into the
nature of struggle itself in
America, the core tension we've
been exploring, it feels
fundamental.
Does America survive by waiting
out movements until exhaustion
prevails, swallowing their
energy into that cultural black
hole?
The graveyard model.
Or does it survive by arguing
itself into coherence, forcing
movements to compost into future
progress, even if it's slow and
messy?
The evolving battleground model,
Yeah.
The answer, as always, probably
lies somewhere in the tension
between those two positions,
right?
Usually does, but the second
source provides a really
powerful moral underpinning to
that struggle, I think it
insists that cynicism is a form
of moral leisure.
Moral leisure, meaning it's easy
to be cynical.
It's easy while maintaining hope
and persistent action is always
the more courageous, the more
demanding act.
And you know, the very fact that
we are engaged in this deep dive
right now, analyzing the fate of
these struggles, critiquing the
critiques, that itself is proof
that the system is still
breathing, it's still contested.
The argument isn't over.
That's a hopeful thought in
itself.
It suggests that America's only
real weapon against that
cultural inertia, against decay,
isn't necessarily a new law or a
corporate mandate.
Maybe not.
It's the act of talking back,
the constant maintenance of
intellectual tension and
argument, that act of persistent
scrutiny.
That's the engine of change,
however slow or frustrating that
treadmill might feel sometimes.
That seems to be the
implication.
The struggle itself is the sign
of life.
OK, so for you, the listener, as
you look at today's cultural and
political shifts, maybe consider
this final thought drawn from
the source material, which
really speaks to the heart of
this whole deep dive.
What is the defining difference,
the functional difference
between progress that
successfully sediments becomes
part of the foundation?
The compost.
And dissent that is merely
curated, illuminated, maybe even
monetized, put in that mausoleum
by the very system it seeks to
change.
Where does the necessary fertile
compost stop and the sealed,
neutralized landfill begin?
That's the question to ponder.
Welcome to the debate.
Our focus today is what's quite
a provocative analogy really
drawn from the source material.
It's this parallel between
Afghanistan, you know, famously
called the graveyard of empires,
and the idea that America might
be, in its own way, a graveyard
of movements.
And this this really centers on
a pretty fundamental
disagreement about how our
political system, our cultural
system actually handles change.
So the question is, does the
American structure ultimately
just absorb and sort of
neutralize the energy of these
big social demands, draining
them until they fail?
Or does it actually process
them, integrate them, allowing
movements to, you know, morph,
maybe compost as the material
suggests, and contribute to
slow, maybe, but lasting
cumulative progress?
OK, for my part, I'll be arguing
for the skeptical view that
America is, structurally
speaking, a graveyard, a place
where deep change often turns
out to be temporary, maybe just
surface level, and ultimately
gets rolled back.
And I can see why that that view
is appealing, especially, yeah,
looking at the last few years of
volatility.
But I do think the graveyard
metaphor, while it's definitely
powerful, it kind of
misunderstands the the long arc
of American history.
So I'll be arguing that America
is more like an evolving
battleground.
Progress here.
Look, it's undeniably slow.
It's uneven.
You have to keep fighting the
same battle sometimes.
But it is cumulative, I think,
and it's lasting.
For me, that struggle itself
isn't really a sign of failure.
It's, well, it's the necessary
engine of our kind of liberal
democracy.
Right.
So my core thesis digging into
that graveyard idea is that
America essentially outlasts its
challengers.
And in this context, the
challengers are these big
movements demanding really
profound cultural structural
shifts, you know, thinking back
to civil rights decades ago or
Occupy Wall Street more
recently.
And this latest wave of social
justice advocacy.
This system, it seems to me,
manages to nullify these demands
using 2 powerful, almost simple
forces, inertia and entropy.
And maybe let's translate those
those sort of academic terms.
Inertia is just the the massive
weight of the existing culture,
existing laws, it's deep
tendency to just stay the same,
right to resist change and kind
of snap back to the average.
And and entropy.
How does that fit in?
Right.
And entropy is, is just the
natural decay of any, any new
system or law or habit, any gain
really, if you're not constantly
supplying immense energy to keep
it going.
And the, I'd say the brilliance,
maybe the insidious brilliance
of the American system is that
it offers surface compliance,
often quite prematurely.
It'll, you know, throw some
resources, offer praise, rewrite
a few rules here and there.
But these superficial changes,
they strategically drain the
movements.
Finite energy, it's fuel.
And once that peak energy fades,
well, entropy kicks in, things
start to decay and inertia, that
huge cultural weight, it just
ensures the gains get rolled
back.
I mean, look at the evidence.
Historically, schools quietly
started resegregating decades
after the big civil rights wins.
Voting rights protections have
been chipped away piece by piece
through courts and legislatures.
And right now, we're seeing DEI
programs being, you know,
quietly dismantled or just
defunded across universities,
corporations.
The system absorbs that initial
shock, that energy, and
ultimately, I'd argue, gives
back nothing truly lasting
instructional terms.
See, I have to, I have to
challenge that conclusion that
the outcome is nothing lasting.
That perspective, I think,
confuses temporary setbacks,
maybe legislative losses, with
total systemic failure.
Change here isn't like flipping
a switch.
It's not just reversible like
that.
It's more recursive, cumulative.
It operates much more like a
spiral.
Maybe movements don't just
collapse into nothing, they
compost.
That's the term used, and I
think it fits their immediate
decay.
It doesn't just vanish, it
actually fertilizes future
growth.
It leaves behind a permanent
residues.
Institutional linguistic.
Think about the anti war
movement back in the 60s and
70s.
OK, they didn't end the Vietnam
War overnight, but they created
this deep widespread almost
institutional skepticism towards
military interventionism that
frankly defines major political
decisions and and public
tolerance for foreign wars even
today.
That's a permanent shift,
wouldn't you say, in the
political consensus?
Similarly, you know, Black Lives
Matter, it fundamentally shifted
public opinion on systemic
racism and policing.
That cultural foundation, that
awareness, It can't just be
unlearned.
Even if the policy changes lag
behind or or face immediate
political backlash.
Backlash actually, in my view
isn't proof of failure.
It's it's overwhelming proof of
impact, the institutional
slowness, that inertia you
mentioned.
I see that as the necessary
price maybe of stability in a
liberal democracy.
It's what protects us critically
from a rapid slide into tyranny
or, you know, radical
centralized power.
OK, let's let's delve into that
idea, that concept of the
composting then, because you're
suggesting this sort of organic
renewal, but I actually see the
system more containing that
energy, kind of sealing it off.
Let's look at the fate of that
initial, you know, revolutionary
fire.
OK, well let's test the
composting idea then.
Take a major example like the
feminist movement.
It's energy didn't just
disappear, right?
It's sedimented into the legal
structure.
It gave rise to Title 9, which I
mean, fundamentally changed
education, athletics in this
country.
And that legal and cultural
scaffolding that then fed
directly into movements we see
today.
Like hashtag Me too, decades
later, the cultural legacy of
these movements, like the push
for diverse, equitable
workplaces that really started
with affirmative action.
Even when the specific laws get
struck down, that legacy can't
just be undone overnight.
It's it's seated into our
professional expectations.
Now.
A whole generation of leaders
carries those values.
And that, to me, is a lasting
institutional legacy.
That's that's a compelling case
for maybe cultural
sedimentation.
Yeah.
But I would frame the
transformation of that energy
differently.
I'm just not convinced it's
compost.
I think the energy isn't
recycled into, you know, civic
soil.
It's more like it gets sealed
into corporate packaging.
It's containment reform gets
domesticated, right?
It gets rendered harmless.
So feminism isn't just Title 9.
It becomes empowerment branding
that you see sold on T-shirts
and mugs.
Black Lives Matter becomes a a
mandatory diversity memo or
maybe a corporate consultation
requirement, but often without
any real shift in say, corporate
spending or or labor practices.
That's quite an indictment
though.
You're basically saying all
these movements just end up as
marketing material.
Functionally, often yes.
The system absorbs the
vocabulary of the movement, and
then it repurposes it as brand
content.
You know, environmentalism
becomes an app where you track
your personal carbon footprint
while the corporation sponsoring
the app continues polluting its
scale.
This turns the system into what
I'd maybe call a mausoleum with
Wi-Fi, right?
Movements get illuminated, they
get hashtag, they get monetized,
they become intellectual
property, essentially.
But structurally, underneath it
all, nothing really breathes.
The market consumes the critical
energy of the movement and then
uses that very energy to fuel
the engine of consumption.
It was supposed to be
challenging in the first place.
But but the very existence of
that Co option or even just the
attempt at Co option, isn't that
direct evidence of the
movement's power?
I mean, it implies the system
had to respond, right?
It faced an external pressure so
significant that just ignoring
it wasn't an option anymore.
The fact that terms like, you
know, the 1% or income
inequality which really exploded
out of Occupy Wall Street are
now absolutely mainstream
political language shaping
election platforms, even
proposals for tax legislation,
that shows a fundamental change
in the very terms of our
economic debate.
That's not just containment,
surely that's that's real
political penetration.
The terms of the debate shift, I
grant you that, but the
underlying conditions often hold
remarkably fast.
And that brings us right back to
that force you see as the
necessary stabilizer, inertia.
Now, I concede, OK,
institutional slowness probably
prevents Coos, prevents wild
radical swings.
But I'd argue that this
stability isn't neutral.
Inertia cushions, well, far, far
better than it cushions justice.
It primarily protects the
beneficiaries of stability.
How do you mean?
Isn't stability inherently
necessary for everyone,
especially the vulnerable?
Yes, stability is needed, but
stability is expensive, and the
question is who pays for it and
who benefits most from it.
Those aren't always the same
groups.
Inertia, the way I see it, means
reforms consistently stall out
at the level of representation
rather than moving towards
genuine redistribution of wealth
or power.
So we see tremendous growth in
diverse faces in positions of
power.
More women, more minorities and
visible leadership roles,
absolutely.
But the fundamental economic
power structures, they remain
largely untouched.
Inertia keeps landlords wealthy.
It keeps major financial
institutions secure.
It keeps corporate profits
soaring, even while the
political class itself becomes
superficially more reflective of
the country's diversity.
It prioritizes capital stability
over, say, Labour's justice.
OK, I see the argument, and I
don't deny that inertia often
has a, well a conservative bias
and practice.
But I think you might be asking
institutional slowness to be
something it just fundamentally
cannot be rapidly egalitarian.
Institutional slowness is
democracy's shock absorber.
It has to be.
We want protection against the
whims of a temporary majority,
don't we?
If we had 0 inertia, imagine it.
We'd have these rapid,
potentially disastrous
legislative overcorrections.
Power would become far too
centralized, far too responsive
to every wave of populist fervor
which historically tends to lead
towards tyranny, not more
justice.
Inertia is simply the arena.
Maybe a frustratingly slow
arena, but a stable, predictable
one, where the long battle for
change has to be fought.
We have to accept the price, the
price of deliberation and
incrementalism, if we want to
avoid the alternatives of
instability and chaos.
I agree we need stability, of
course, but my concern is that
the very incrementalism you
praise leads only to what feels
like dynamic equilibrium.
This perpetual churn, lots of
motion, but ultimately 0 net
displacement on that critical
axis of wealth and power.
And that leads directly to my
view of the historical
direction.
I see the appearance of motion,
yes, but I argue the system is
essentially designed as a highly
sophisticated treadmill.
Whereas I'm maintaining
historical record absolutely
points to a spiral, not a
treadmill.
A spiral means, yes, each wave
might revisit old ground, tackle
similar issues, but always from
a significantly higher altitude.
The gains are cumulative and
some, I'd argue, become
essentially irreversible.
Think about same sex marriage.
Just a generation ago.
It was literally unthinkable for
the vast majority of Americans.
But the legislative groundwork,
the cultural groundwork laid
over decades led to a
fundamental normalization that
isn't just going to be rolled
back by the next election cycle.
Or look at the dramatic shift in
women's status.
I mean, women now make up the
majority of college graduates.
That's a fundamental economic
and cultural reality built on
decades of tireless suffragist
and feminist activism.
These aren't just cyclical
fluctuations, they are profound
cumulative cultural shifts
built, I'd say, on the compost
of past movements.
I certainly acknowledge those
cultural shifts, the educational
shifts, absolutely, but I still
question the net displacement on
the economic axis.
The system seems brilliantly
designed to give every
generation the feeling of moving
forward.
And look, in some ways maybe it
is.
But the underlying machinery,
the machinery of consumption, of
global capitalism, it ensures
that each so-called revolution
just becomes another product
cycle.
We protest inequality while, you
know, holding and using devices
built by exploited labor in
global supply chains.
We decry the system's injustice
using the system's own
infrastructure, social media,
etcetera to get our message out.
The incline, the steep incline
of inequality.
It feels like it remains even if
the scenery gets updated with
new tech, new slogans, new
brands of activism.
It feels like a highly
sophisticated treadmill designed
to keep the core power dynamics
exactly where they are while
granting us the illusion of
perpetual progress.
Well, I think this tension we're
exploring, it's actually
incredibly productive.
I honestly believe America
evolves precisely because it
manages to outlast that easy
cynicism, that graveyard
metaphor.
The system endures not by
destroying its movements, but by
internalizing their demands.
OK, slowly and perfectly, yes,
but internalizing them
nonetheless.
The ongoing, often frustrating
fight for justice is the
democratic process itself, and
that ensures change, however
slow it feels, is ultimately
cumulative.
It's ongoing.
The very endurance of these
movements, even when they get Co
opted into corporate memos or
feel temporarily quieted, that's
evidence of systemic life I
think, not futility.
In my position, just to restate
remains that America survives
largely by draining its
challengers through this process
of strategic absorption, its
core identity, particularly that
fundamental economic structure
and the inherent structural bias
of inertia, remains remarkably
intact.
Movements get metabolized,
turned into harmless commercial
efforts or PR campaigns, and for
the actual reformer, the choice
too often seems to be either
assimilation into the
establishment or just sheer
exhaustion.
It's a remarkably efficient self
preserving system in that sense.
Yet the strength of the system,
might argue, is that we are
internal to it.
This fight for justice isn't
some external invasion that the
system can just wait out, like
an empire in Afghanistan.
It is the internal mechanism of
change.
Afghanistan perhaps survives by
waiting out empires.
America, I think, evolves by
arguing itself and arguing for
itself into some kind of
coherence, however messy.
Indeed, and the source material
really forces us to confront
this deep tension.
We've looked at whether reform
energy is composted and
recycled, or if it ends up
sealed in a corporate landfill
contained.
We've debated if institutional
slowness is primarily about
necessary stability, or if it
mainly functions to rotect
established wealth.
The evidence, as we've
discussed, is pretty robust on
both sides.
Ultimately, the listener has to
weigh this evidence and
determine whether the long game
here in America feels more like
a steep upward spiral or just a
highly sophisticated,
perpetually moving treadmill.
Welcome back.
Today we're diving into this
really interesting essay.
It argues America is essentially
a graveyard of movements.
Yeah, the idea that it absorbs
and neutralizes change efforts,
almost like Afghanistan absorbs
empires through sheer inertia.
Right, a provocative start, so
let's jump right in.
The initial premise, It's
definitely compelling.
It is.
It sets the stage well, you
know, America outlasting
frustrating change.
But where I think it gets really
original is when it shift gears
a bit away from just passive
resistance and into active
absorption.
That's the key distinction for
me.
The Afghanistan analogy works as
an opener, but it's mostly about
that slow reversion, that
entropy.
Exactly.
And that leads to our first big
point.
The critique really needs to
elevate that later concept, the
uniquely American way of
neutralizing things.
You know the caring curating
containing that should be front
and center in the argument.
The essay mentions the system
smiling, applauding funding.
Right, filing it under corporate
social responsibility.
Yeah.
But it presents that as just
like a slow drain when what it's
actually describing feels much
more sophisticated.
It's curation.
It's monetization.
Absolutely, and the author does
get there later with phrases
like metabolizing descent or
that great line mausoleum with
Wi-Fi.
Fantastic line.
But the weaknesses, well,
burying that insight, it comes
across almost as a footnote to
the main inertia idea.
Doesn't that kind of undersell
the most distinctive part of the
argument?
I think it does.
So what if we suggest reframing
the whole thesis right from the
start?
Prioritize assimilation and
branding over just, you know,
outlasting things.
OK, so shift the core metaphor
instead of a passive black hole
just sucking things in slowly.
It's an active metabolizing
entity that feels much stronger,
much more original, doesn't it?
It does.
It immediately changes the
question for the reader.
It's less how long till this
movement fizzles out and more
OK.
How is so like a concrete
example?
Maybe introduce that mausoleum
with Wi-Fi idea way earlier.
Make that the central image, not
something safe for the
conclusion.
Yes, and pull those specific.
Examples forward to the essay
already has them like feminism
becoming empowerment branding or
BLM becoming ADEI memo those.
Aren't just side effects, they
are the mechanism.
Use those sharp examples right
in the main body to show the
process in action, clarifying
that America isn't just Outlast.
Movements.
It actively incorporates the
opposition to maintain its
equilibrium, and it even
incorporates the backlash
against the.
Movements, which is fascinating.
You know, the way anti DEI
arguments get folded into this
narrative about meritocracy.
That's such a good point.
The system basically says.
OK, we can.
Argue about how we define
fairness, but the underlying
economic structure that stays
put, that level of strategic Co
option.
That's the real innovation this
essay has identified.
It needs to be the headline.
OK, that's a perfect bridge
actually to the second.
Area dealing with complexity or
maybe the counter arguments
right because the essay it does
focus quite.
Heavily on the rollback aspect,
you know, schools resegregating,
voting rights getting hit, and
that stuff is real.
It's demonstrably.
True, But focusing only on that,
well, it risks sounding
terminally cynical, doesn't it?
It opens the door to easy
dismissal.
That's the worry.
So to make the.
Thesis stronger, less vulnerable
Maybe the structure needs to
proactively address the other
side, the idea that progress is
recursive, that movements do
leave things behind The compost
idea the compost idea right
because the essays current.
Focus on the snap back it kind
of.
Overlooks those undeniable
sedimented gains.
Think about how Occupy change
the language around inequality
or the legal foundations laid by
the civil rights movement.
That other movements built on.
You can't just ignore that
exactly, so the suggestion isn't
to like.
Concede the point or week in the
argument.
It's to integrate that idea of
sedimentation early on.
Acknowledge it, but frame it as
part of the neutralization
process.
Precisely acknowledge stuff.
Gets left behind, but then hit
them with the real threat that
the product of the sedimentation
isn't fertile compost.
It's containment.
It's landfill.
Landfill versus compost.
I like that.
It keeps the critique sharp.
It lets the essays nuance really
shine.
You can confront the progress
argument head on, say OK,
culturally, maybe affirmative
actions, legacy of diverse
workplaces can't be fully
undone.
But then immediately pivot to
how the system uses the
backlash, the push for color
blindness or whatever to stop
redistribution while maybe
allowing a bit of surface level
representation.
Yeah, the system is incredibly
selective.
About what parts of a movement
it actually keeps.
It takes the optics, leaves the
power shift, and we could
contrast that compost idea
directly.
You know, say, composting needs
gardeners, people actively
tending the soil for future
growth.
But America mostly offers what
exactly?
Marketers who just.
Seal the moral energy inside
shiny corporate packaging that
turns the whole optimistic
counter argument into proof of
the essay's main point in
touching on inertia again, the
idea that it's.
Democracy shock absorber.
Yeah, OK, maybe it is, but the
essay?
Needs to be explicit about who
benefits from that shock
absorption.
It stabilizes things mostly for
well, for the.
Beneficiaries of stability,
right?
Landlords, wealth holders, Not
necessarily for justice, right?
It slows down progress,
definitely.
But when it comes to rolling
back economic gains for the
powerful, suddenly inertia
doesn't seem so strong.
It's selective that selectivity
is key, and it makes you.
Think if inertia protects the
status quo, then maybe those
quick visible winds movement
sometimes get the easy
concessions.
Maybe they're actually a trap.
How so?
Well, maybe they drain the
movement's energy faster,
sapping the will needed for the
really long, slow, difficult
work of changing actual
structures.
I see the sugar rush that.
Prevents you from eating the
actual meal.
Something like that and that
analysis the.
Drain from easy wins the
containment through
monetization.
It leads directly to the essays
really powerful conclusion that
idea that reform must survive
assimilation, which is such a
profound challenge.
And it brings us neatly to our
final critique.
OK, that concluding call to
action survive assimilation.
It needs to be well
operationalized a bit more.
We need clear strategic
takeaways for activists, right?
The diagnosis is brilliant.
It nails how movements get
drained and contained.
But the practical advice on what
a successful, lasting movement
actually does it feels a bit
hinted at rather than spelled
out.
You know, like needing ideas to
persist after the cameras leave.
But how do they persist?
What does that look like?
In practice, exactly the
prescription needs to be as.
Sharp as the diagnosis so the
suggestion here is to lay out
specific criteria what must a
movement achieve to avoid
getting buried or curated and
base those criteria directly on
the failure modes the essay
identifies OK so if the system
is great at.
Absorbing protest policies and
slogans, then the changes
movements aim for need to be
things that are hard to brand.
Things that can't just be rolled
back by the next administration
or policy shift.
Well, maybe focusing on genuine
redistribution rather than just
representation or cultural
optics.
Things that fundamentally alter
power dynamics in ways that are
resistant to being turned into a
corporate slogan that makes
sense and if the system.
Uses easy winds to drain energy.
Then the counter strategy has to
be embedded in.
How the movement operates right?
Maybe deliberately avoiding the
pursuit of quick surface
compliance and instead
prioritizing what?
Building long term
self-sustaining community
structures, focusing energy on
maintenance to fight that
entropy.
Yes, instead of just celebrating
the quick.
Flashy winds that might
ultimately be shallow.
It's about building something
durable and building it
independently because.
The essay implies reformers are
often critiquing a system they
rely on for funding for
platforms, so a concrete example
could be.
Suggesting activists need to
consciously build
infrastructure, financial
infrastructure, communication
infrastructure that's
independent of the corporate
economy and the social media
algorithms they're often
fighting against, that feels
like the strategic core of.
Surviving assimilation.
True independence?
Exactly.
It's moving from.
Critique to strategy.
This has been really productive.
I think so.
Just to recap the main
opportunities we see for making
this already powerful essay even
more impactful.
OK, first, really sharpening
that core metaphor, emphasizing
the active curation and
metabolization over just
passively outlasting things,
making that the central engine.
Got it.
Second.
Strengthening the argument
structure by tackling that
counter thesis, the compost or
sedimentation idea head on.
Frame it not as progress but as
a form of selective containment.
That landfill idea?
Yeah, landfill, not compost, it
guards.
Against easy optimism and
finally making that powerful
call to survive assimilation
more concrete operationalizing
it by defining specific, maybe
non market.
Based criteria for what lasting
change looks like.
Things like focusing on
maintenance, existing branding,
building, financial
independence, right turning that
brilliant diagnosis.
Into a truly strategic road map,
these steps, we think will
really elevate the.
Analysis shifting it from just
identifying America's unique
power structure to offering a
potent challenge and guide for
future efforts absolutely so we
strongly.
Encourage you to explore these
ideas, revise the material and
please send it back to us.
We'd love to take another look.